naja was soll ich euch sagen das wäre
kein video von mir wenn ich mich
irgendwie technische probleme hätte und
aus irgendeinem grund ist der ton von
unserer anmoderation weg ich bin nach
hamburg zur luca gefahren weil nerf uns
beide zu einer change aufgefordert hat
und zwar sollten wir mit den neuen nerv
ultra blaster gegeneinander antreten in
einer koch challenge was natürlich sehr
passen kann und wir machen das ganze
natürlich nicht mit irgendwelchen
ablassen sondern mit dem neuen f altra
ventoux die haben dort die fliegen bis
zu 36 meter weit was wir natürlich
gleich auch noch testen werden die haben
da für diese ziele vorbereitet sind
appelius brokkoli champignons bacon
dreist tomate luca sardellen seine
nudeln zwiebeln an den werden wir gleich
unsere zielgenauigkeit hessen aber
natürlich wollten wir dafür erst mal die
ultra blaster auf herz und nieren testen
sebastian hat sich dahinter eine ecke
versteckt werden dass getestet und soll
ja was machst du gerade
dann habe ich nochmal trauern mit 25
schuss trommel magazin ausgepackt und
plötzlich war der ton wieder da so sieht
das nämlich auch wenn man es richtig
macht ich meine das bringt mich und
raffiniert weil ich habe trotzdem nur
fünf schüsse aber guck mal
alter schwede loslegt ich habe sogar
noch nach weil ich bin bestens
vorbereitet aber wir gehen jetzt erst
mal zurück das sind sogar fünf meter und
du hast den ersten versuch locker weil
wir sind hier bei dir das heim partei
kommt also ich würde auch die nudeln
geht ok ja verständlich nudeln sind
somit das beste deshalb erreichen wir
haben heute grundlage auch die nudeln
nudeln ja auch direkt gedrosselt
liga erst mal dass europa die haben das
einfach aus dem rahmen braucht und ich
habe das richtig ein das auch iris
präzise das war der erste schuss von
dahinten ja das hat echt was werd ich
versuche dann jetzt weil ich brauche
auch eine grundlage für meinen gericht
ich probiere den reis zu treffen
pejcic aquaro gesperrt
man guckt über dieses zielfernrohren man
kann ultra genau zielen ok dann müssen
sie es auf jeden fall überlegen was
brauchen wir als nächstes zu tat bisher
würde ich sagen sind wir echt gut
unterwegs ich habe mir schon was
ausgeguckt also ich habe richtig bock
auf entweder broccoli mit den indern
sogar von 18 uhr kochen dann mit
vokuhila fahne oder die eier ich will
genau die beiden sachen brauche ich auch
okay das kann also nur gewinnen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
habt ihr das gesehen hat weiß schon was
die benutzt ihr einfach so ein bisschen
zum würzen nach hause kommst weiter
geht's da luca immerhin habe ich zwei
zutaten nicht die eier die wollte als
nächstes habe eine harmonika
verteidiger was los reis sei denn ich
bin schon ich bin schon verloren aber
ich probiert ja ich probier brokkoli
noch dazu gehören weil die pasta fällt
ja mein gott ich bin so ein sniper ich
habe drei zutaten eier brokkoli reiße
ich brauche irgendeine saucen basis noch
und wir haben hier noch sahne passt
überhaupt nicht glaube ich versuche auf
welches zu geben obwohl es mit das
kleinste ist ja so carbonara mäßig
welche und ist schon schwer zu treffen
okay das doch okay egal was du treffer
so tat ich habe ihn was getroffen hat
wie gar nicht ich geh jetz auch zu
machen
da hab ich schon von hinten dann gebe
ich dir kommen ab die das gesehen und
hoffe nicht genug denn ich habe von ja
ich habe dieser denn ich hab ihn okay
okay was noch eine extra schuss als
joker das stimmt doerfert anrufen hat
gesagt hat wie jeder noch einen extra
schuss hand nur kann und darf wie immer
den vortritt wir waren anscheinend
bisher einfach nicht zielsicher durch
meinen aus fünf schüssen aus du drei und
vier dass die schon logisch denken
backstage ob das wirklich das passt auch
perfekt zu den anderen zutaten spreche
ich dafür diesen da kannst du das
geistes machen auf dienstag etwas wo ich
mir denn jetzt würde sagen zwiebeln
zwiebel kleines ziel aber ich muss es
schaffen aber ich meine selbst betroffen
ziel ich hoffe ich doch dass ich habe
nicht mal hingeschaut
ich habe nicht mal hingeschaut werden
erst das dienst kümmert hat alter mamma
mia
wir haben jetzt alle unsere zutaten zu
sagen jetzt kann es losgehen mit dem
kochen wir werden das schon mal sehr
lecker
du machst das ganze jetzt aber ich fange
einfach schon mal eine zwischenzeit
anzukommen wir haben hier unsere zutaten
ich habe fünf auf 68 4 aus 6
bei mir sieht es ganz gut aus nur die
sardellen müssen halt einfach nicht
sagen na ja also ich werde auf jeden
fall so vorgehen dass die nudeln erst
mal kochen werde dann zehn minuten in
der zeit schneidet die champignons ein
bisschen ich hab noch nie gekocht werden
nicht mag deswegen keine ahnung wie
schmecken wird und dann werde ich auf
jeden fall die gekochten nudeln der
falle packen
willst du dazu ja dazu dazu noch einmal
von vorne machen
pfeffer sei sowas muss man natürlich
nicht verstehen aber ich fange jetzt
erst mal an mit meinen tomaten daraus
macht nimmt die sich halbiere erstmal
hier meine cherrytomaten wie gesagt da
raus muss ich die soße machen weil ich
hab ja sonst nicht versuchst du hast
auch schon eine richtige soosten basis
ich mag eine soße ich weiß nicht was ich
gemacht aber ich will einfach nur so
kleine stückchen machen ihnen die keine
ahnung also das mache ich jetzt quasi
fertig ich mache dann mache ich die
chance doch fertig und habe ich
eigentlich schon mein wasser kocht auf
jeden fall deswegen kommt jetzt ein
bisschen salz weil ich packe meinen
nudeln reis gekocht auch videos
mach das nicht nein damit passten die
nicht so aneinander und auf den proben
waren ja auch lohnen
ich mache das ist also ich bin hier am
kochen gegendemo kohli vor ganz genau
eine haarige angelegenheit gar nicht
super viel genutzte packen alles noch
mal thema zurück tun
die nudel uwe barth sagt helga will man
diese aussage am 3 aber da hätte ich
mich doch nicht blöd da ich bin die
kinos bringen
dadurch dass der reichen so ein koch
beutel ist werde ich reich sind im
kochbuch
dadurch könnte aber dem roten leben
gleichen topf mit zubereiten profi im
gleichen topf wie können wir sind besser
und das auch mal gut oder werden kann es
oft besser kommen jetzt wird es jetzt
ein bisschen sogar extra war hier kochen
status studio der flöte seit quetschen
und hätte man das nicht eigentlich so
mit dem gucken damit man sich nicht die
finger teilweise was gerade so wie ich
das war die idee nicht doch jetzt geht
eine vorbereitung sind du hast einfach
mein wasser nicht auch heiß gestellt
dass bissen runter gestellt
damit will er selber gucken wir geben
auch bei der fan hier richtig gas wir
werden nämlich jetzt die cherrytomaten
ein bisschen auskochen umso daraus
hoffentlich einen kennst
wo entstehen zu lassen sind leider nicht
super viele die ich bekommen habe aber
es ist wie es ist
ich gebe jetzt ein wenig purine zu
meinem format und jetzt würde ich meinen
reisen beraten werde sei hier
ich werde jetzt etwa richter ist nicht
genutzt wird und gibt mir einen traum
wenn wir mal ein bisschen in die
asiatische küche reingeschnuppert in
bio- und da habe ich tatsächlich tauchte
getrocknete nicht vom tisch auch so
entscheiden und das sind die aastra de
luca des kriegs modus aktiviert der
fälle gerufen wurde wird diese ernsthaft
kriegt lukas und das finde ich sehr
bemerkenswert für zunehmend zum kopf
also in seine stories wird auch immer
wieder gekauft somit den anfängen nicht
so gegeben jetzt in brokkoli plätze dazu
in das wasser ständig erstmal genau
stimmen
die tschechische marke fallen jetzt so
langsam ein dann gehen wir auch schon
und jetzt habe ich schon alle zutaten
beinahe alle zutaten verwendet wir
helfen jetzt mal ein bisschen nach
drücken wie kirschgarten ein bisschen
platt was soll mich eine möglichst
homogene soße ergeben
wenig los die nudeln brauche ich erstmal
ein bisschen abgekühlt wasser so mann
max lassen sich nur ein gericht kochen
wenn der zwischenzeit wurden jetzt ein
bisschen chillen haue ich meine fahne
komplett anders denken weil ja fast
schon das inzwischen erreichte jetzt
einmal ab hier gilt dass ich dieses teil
dann drauf hauen weil sonst die ganzen
die ganzen sachen ineinander jetzt macht
das entfacht sich der komplette
geschmack film tron das ist gar nicht
gehört hat leute die kamera gegeben aus
wie jetzt so heiß war kommunikation
bürgermeister paul handy macht ob es
wirklich nicht schlechter dinger
reinzumachen wenn jetzt ein bisschen
nicht schon gar sind so bin ich gut der
reißt es jetzt fertig
ich habe den kommenden top ten der fürst
otto von der tabellenkonstellation ich
möchte alles zusammen ich finde die
ausstellung gehört von direct irgendwas
irgendwas reden aber irgendwie leichter
nichts und niemand sonst wieder auf die
klassische spannend und schön durch und
ich probiere macht
hat er ihn dritte auf jeden fall drin
[Musik]
wir haben mit unseren nachbarn die
zutaten für dieses ersten er spielte
bastian du hast hier einmal ich stelle
es kurz vor zwölf frei trice mit
sardellen und was mir bei dir
wir haben hier schöne agentin nudeln in
einem kochtopf enden zu lassen dann
haben wir das in einer pfanne getan mit
ein wenig öl salz pfeffer abgeschmeckt
lass dir schmecken sebastian ich weiß
nicht ob es dort alles drin war aber mal
schauen so wissen eine carbonara
carbonara wir haben den feinsten daumen
aus ganz deutschland eingeladen
ich finde es lustig dass essen warum
lassen wir das essen
warum macht ihr das essen aus ja und der
fifa 10 von 10 punkten
es ist irgendwie zu viel das eis zu viel
auf einmal so also die all die stücke
vom eis noch zu groß ich muss aber sagen
du hast damit die redet niemand gedacht
einen guten tester in sebastian unten
weil der würde sich so was auch kommen
bis ein bisschen viel für meinen
geschmack bisschen ungleichmäßige salzen
wie gesagt diese eierstöcke zu groß ist
dann teilweise sogar zu maxis leute
erreicht hatten ganz guten bisher was
sagst du zu den anderen kommunen jetzt
gerade habe ich die zwiebeln schmeckt
immer noch bis das nicht zuletzt kann so
eine note von den kartellen gerade durch
finde ich aber nicht ganz verkehrt hat
in dem moment so was wie sowas von bayer
mit tomaten sind auch lange genug
schlecht geworden in der
jetzt will ich auch erwartet werden wir
nicht ganz klar der meinung auf jeden
fall tomaten sind existieren ja
kommentaren leute normalerweise ist
unterstützung verschwunden
tatsächlich jetzt irgendwann mal gezeigt
zum abschluss ich kann mich noch mal
kurz freuen
also ich muss sagen alles ist wie alles
andere wäre zehn von zehn und was hat
max
damit bin ich der gewinner der challenge
man muss dazu sagen wir haben beide
nicht die perfekten zutaten gehabt wir
haben es aber auch sehr simpler ich bin
wirklich stolz was mich auch wenn du das
war natürlich ein spaß luca und ich
verstehen uns bestens und es hat sehr
viel spaß gemacht das ganze heute war
mal was neues und dann eine challenge
wir uns nur auf tankstelle dann hat sehr
viel spaß gemacht und ich würde sagen
wir sehen uns im nächsten video